folded paper shapes son an old wall in
Paris the transient artwork is called
ephemera ephemeral
the French artist who goes by the name
of Mademoiselle Maryse says public
spaces are perfect for showing her works
on the job rescue salumi you they're the
best means of expression and of reaching
many people I can make the city which is
so grey with its buildings and concrete
a bit more colorful the artist has been
working with origami installations for
more than two years now in addition to
her native France
she's also exhibited her work in many
other countries for example Hong Kong
Vietnam and Japan where she also lived
for a year actually it all started when
I was in Japan because you find and see
origami everywhere there it's also an
art form that comes from there in Japan
there's a legend that a wish will come
true if you make a thousand origami
cranes fabrication the mean paisan and
pipe shape
origami is the art of folding paper
madam was a Maurice does her folding in
her small Paris studio the 29 year old
taught herself the technique using a
book
she uses five different designs the bird
the crane the wind the boat and the
flower our origami classics I usually
need about 800 to 1500 pieces for an
installation it depends on the size of
the surface said they polish offers
after finishing her studies Mademoiselle
Maryse worked as an architect but soon
felt creatively stifled so she set out
to find her own artistic style
she started by photographing people and
objects with a fisheye lens she went on
to experimenting with thread her first
work of street art was made of ribbons
and then she invented another form of
street art using origami the feeding
nature of her work is intentional
now off its aha
I want to make installations that are
ephemeral they reflect human existence
which is also fleeting and that fact is
something that keeps me from taking my
work too seriously and I can reuse the
pieces from one installation to another
isn't it easy installation Charlotte the
first major retrospective of her work is
currently on show and ablate still a
home in western France more than 40
artworks are on display in a 120 square
metre gallery
among them are portraits made from
recycled paper the artist says she wants
her work to encourage people to take a
closer look at the environment
this glass sculpture explores the
subject of deforestation
the red claw I was very very happy and
honored to be able to exhibit my work in
such a large space it gave me the
feeling I could express myself without
limits she's already working on a new
installation in Paris the heart is
dedicated to her grandmother who always
supported her passers-by often engage
her in conversation as she works
the reactions motivator
we limit yes positive emotions are very
important to me it pleases me to touch
people in a positive way and make some
smile
uh e-excuse me prolly to shock everyone
Mademoiselle Maurice will soon be
hitting the road again her next project
is an installation in Singapore